just because kids will figure out a way
to see the suicide squad it doesn't mean
they'll understand
everything they see in the movie here
are some r-rated or otherwise
adult moments in the suicide squad that
will sort over the heads of younger
viewers
although they're never seen we are
informed that nazis built gotenheim
after world war
ii when they came to courtois maltese
seeking asylum
and hoping to continue their experiments
couple this for the eventual reveal of
jotenheim's inner workings where
faceless prisoners are held in obscene
conditions
shuffling their feet in cramped cells
and you get a fictional horror
reflecting a real one
for an adult such imagery coupled with
the words nazi
brings to mind the most repulsive
horrors mankind has ever witnessed
including painful often deadly
experiments on thousands of prisoners
without their permission
of course none of this involves an
enormous starfish from outer space
but as an adult there's a reason why
words like nazi and experiments
carry connotations with such power that
a blockbuster filmmaker would invoke
them
when trying to elicit a sense of
repulsion from his audience
so while the superhero subject matter
may sometimes be silly
that doesn't make it any less of a good
opportunity to engage the young person
in your life
about the very real horrors that once
unfolded here on planet earth
when an adult hears the very first word
spoken in this movie hello i'm johnny
cash
perhaps they'll realize they're hearing
folsom prison blues
a song the legendary man in black
performed to a crowd of inmates
at folsom state prison in 1968 against
the wishes of many this performance and
the groundbreaking live album that came
with it
gave inmates hope and made them feel
like human beings
something very important to cash who was
a hero to the working class
downtrodden and incarcerated until the
day he died
appropriately the song plays over
footage of savant sitting in prison
occupying himself with a bouncy ball in
the same vein when an adult hears a
rousing track
people who died play over the opening
credits perhaps they'll realize that
this is a song by poet and punk rocker
jim carroll
and that all of those people in the song
really did die in the ways being
described
for greater detail about many of those
unfortunate acquaintances of carol
born to a working class irish family in
new york's lower east side perhaps the
adults may have read carol's
autobiographical book the basketball
diaries
or at least seen the 1995 leonardo
dicaprio film
of the same name that starred leo as
carole
[Music]
from louis prima to pixies the suicide
squad soundtrack is as catchy as it is a
gateway to multiple generations
and the multiple subtext these musicians
bring to mind
james gunn is a master using pop music
to give added dimension to a scene
and he selects most of his soundtracks
while he writes his films
creating scenes around the feelings and
associations that a song carries with it
to a younger person maybe this song just
sounds cool so this is your chance to
talk about
music old and new and the more they know
about these musicians the more they'll
appreciate the film next time they watch
it
a couple decades back an urban legend
spread from coast to coast about a
certain movie star who will not be named
here you have search engines
who supposedly had a thing for gerbils
it's not true but it evidently captured
the imagination of an entire generation
many of whom probably still think
there's something to it flash forward to
today and you have an antagonistic
dynamic in the suicide squad between
ratcatcher 2 and the thinker
in one contentious moment she asked him
do you want a dozen angry rodents
crawling up your ass
to which he responds my answer may not
be what you expect
the exchange seems more likely to get a
laugh from an adult than a teen
possibly because that adult remembers
the pre-internet days when the urban
legend was spread from locker room to
locker room
it also perhaps reflects a generational
divide with an older person more likely
to laugh at another's perceived kink
while younger generations are probably
more apt to expect anything
so teens tolerate your mom and dad if
they laugh at that joke there's a whole
history behind it
adults don't be upset if your teen says
you shouldn't laugh at such things
tolerance and acceptance are never bad
instincts to possess
even when we're simply over analyzing a
throwaway line about the sex life of a
fictional evil genius with wires and
metal sticking out of his head
to a younger person viola davis's amanda
waller is a quasi bad guy who deploys
task force x on their mission
and blows up their heads if they try to
escape but if you're an adult who knows
anything about the source material
you're aware that water has been the
driving force of this modern suicide
squad
since the late 80s and is far and away
its most morally complex character
in 1987 secret origins issue 14
we learned that waller grew up in
chicago had five kids
and then watched her son killed daughter
attacked and husband slaughtered while
trying to avenge them
when the police refused to help she had
to wear wiggle and determination to go
back to school
use her education to land a job with the
federal government
and then embark on a mission to make
sure meta humans would never hurt
civilians again
kinda gives you pause when you consider
that wallah being knocked unconscious by
her mutineering staff is played as a
triumphant moment worth cheering
want to engage a young person in your
life in a conversation about the
shortcomings of law enforcement
the desire to take the law into your own
hands and why that can make the problem
worse
the slippery slope of vengeance the
moral implications of treating prisoners
are something less than human beings
with rights
amanda waller is your gateway while it's
easy to watch a superhero film and say
batman is a vigilante isn't that cool
it's a lot more important
and hopefully rewarding to delve into
the moral complexities of such
characters
sooner or later every kid needs to learn
that most people aren't good or bad
but instead dwell in the gray area
between
i'm a superhero perhaps no superhero
series depicts characters in that gray
area better than the suicide squad
movies
where villains are heroes heroic figures
hide their darkest secrets
and the monster at the end of the movie
is a sudden interstellar captive
subjected to decades of rendition who
knows such a discussion might not just
be good parenting but it might also give
them a deeper appreciation for the movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the suicide squad are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one